mgtow is men going their own way so
what does that mean so so you can go
young
so mgtow is let's say there's a spectrum
right okay and in the middle is like the
balanced perspective you want to be the
most balanced possible far left is like
male feminist the guy at the rally with
the [ __ ] hat on
[Laughter]
do you honestly believe i'm like no but
because this is my thing like they
people believe that i'm this like the
guy with the [ __ ] hat
when all i say i'm like just don't why
you have to be a dick about it like a
lot of this feels like
i'm the victim being a man is so hard
women
they just
are i have to be like dude just shut the
[ __ ] up
don't be a dick to women
just be the best version of yourself
don't be a dick to anyone
that's it and like it's not it i feel
like a lot of the red pill is also like
yeah it's like very pessimistic like
yeah and so it's like real i'm dude i'm
just being a realist but everything is
pessimism there's no light i love that
because going back to that to me it goes
i asked i asked robert green of the 48
laws of power ask them a question i said
i said from all your research from all
your understanding from all things that
you've done do you believe most human
beings
have good intentions and occasionally do
bad things or do most human beings have
bad intentions and occasionally do good
things
robert greene told me
he believes most human beings have good
intentions and occasionally do bad
things what do you believe
i agree with that i think that most
people have good intentions and they'll
occasionally do some bad things and
obviously there's some a few bad apples
and i think there was a stat that
um 95 of the this was a former cia fbi
operative he came into valuetainment he
said well you know 95 of the world
does do good things wants to do good
things but then the five percent but if
you take five percent of eight billion
people 100 and that's you know quick
math a couple hundred million it's like
yeah that's why you got so many [ __ ]
crazy people out there and i mean i
totally agree with that i think most
people do good things and just arrive
good intentions they occasionally do bad
things but then those good intentions
are subjective right because i think
take the example with putin right now he
thinks he's doing a good thing yeah the
entire world is like dude he can [ __ ]
invade a country but he's like i gotta
do it for russia yeah you disagree with
robert green i agree with him okay and
so i asked him is this true for men and
is this true for women he said yes
so it goes back to that framework what
do you believe the other person's
intentions are so one of my biggest
criticisms of the red pill movement
happened because most people don't know
this about the podcast is that i try to
be as balanced as possible i try to get
far right and far left i want to i want
i want um roland martin i want umar
johnson i also want candace owens you
know i i want everybody i want to learn
from everybody of course and so
i got some guys who people consider like
the opposite of bread pill i interviewed
them what is that that's blue pill what
does that mean they would consider these
guys blue pill men i don't consider them
that but the internet would consider
them that so what what's blue so
basically the concept of blue pill is
going back to the matrix is like you're
oblivious to the truth and you're living
in a lie so you're so like basically
just want to feel secure you don't want
to have bad things happening you don't
want the harshness of the real world
so like basically a person who would
quote-unquote be blue pill is a person
who's naive to the realities of life
they think you know
women are these perfect angels and if
you just love them just enough every
woman will love you equally right it's
not it either yeah it's not
it's neither right
so i'm gonna explain to you the
criticism because i i hope that i'll
answer your question
so i went on tour
with three of the biggest dating coaches
in the world and i was the camera guy
i went on tour with three of the biggest
data coaches in the world it was um
derrick jackson the guy red pill guys
hate um they really hate this guy my
mentor stefan labosia is a beast and a
guy who another guy they don't really
like name ace metaphor i want to tour
with these three guys
and on this tour
we there it was 95 women
and we would go to these venues
thousands of women
atlanta miami new york man it's fun
but
and i sat and i was a camera guy and
they at the end of each show they would
do a q a
and they'll do this q a and it will get
these women to talk about their issues
and ask the guys questions
and during this time is when i learned
the most about women because i was
actually meeting not online not reading
a book not watching a bunch of guys
bringing girls that they've chosen and
curated i just met thousands of
different women and got to hear them all
talk and i would hear them talk about
things about men and you would hear
these generalizations all men cheat men
are liars why do men do this why do and
you would hear them complain and then
you'll see a woman who's respectfully
like 350 pounds and was like we're all
the good guys that all i find is guys
who wants sex with me men are not
serious it's like well maybe you got in
your best shape and you got physically
fit you could change your outcomes
radical accountability radical
accountability so i would i would
talk about radical so i would see i
would see all these things and i'll be
like this is crazy like they they first
they would over generalize
then they would not take accountability
so
move forward fast forward to now i'm in
the men's space
and literally the same things i heard
from the women i hear from the guys
radical generalizations of women usually
like david said from a pessimistic
worldview because the truth is
pessimistic the truth is that most women
are actually good people with good
attention and do bad things the truth is
most women are selfish hypergamous
people out to get you to take half your
money to take custody of your kids from
you
that's these messages that are being
communicated and then there's a lack of
accountability well the average women
don't want average men
these girls don't want us there's not
accountability where yo do you know if
you put in the work for the next five
years to become your best version of
yourself you would no longer be average
if you held three years if you put in
three years of work you would no longer
be average so that that whole sentence
wouldn't apply to you i would see both
these things
and i would see how bitter and hurt the
women were because if because the reason
you're so emotional is because you were
bitter and you were hurt by a god that's
what caused generalizations you these
women were hurt by men they become
bitter they then they generalize
and then i saw the guys the same thing
guys would call me
guys would call me in
and i will see a lot of these guys are
hurt when your girlfriend cheated on you
how do you feel you're hurt when your
wife divorced you took your money how do
you feel your hurt when your baby mama
took away custody of your children
you're paying child support how do you
feel you're hurt when a girl of your
dreams told you that you're an ugly
loser i'll never be with you how do you
feel you're hurt the guys are hurt and i
called it for what it was and they're
acting emotional not logical is that
basically what you're saying i'm not
saying that
yes but my main point was that they got
offended when i said they were hurt
when you are hurt yeah and and they they
take it like it's a sign of weakness as
a man to be hurt i've been hurt you've
been hurt we've all been hurt there's
nothing wrong with a man being hurt i'm
just calling it for what it is
and so to me like i said the the problem
with all these things is at the end of
the day my goal is that if any man is
listening to this message
if they take anything from what we
communicated
if you simply view the opposite gender
as the villain and you the victim you
will never win exactly you will never
win you will it's just impossible
because it's because think about it
imagine there's a woman who views men as
the villain and she's a victim what a
man of character would a man of
integrity would a man of sensibility
want to be for no she would be too
negative he wouldn't want to stay over
for long so the same thing is true as a
man and also if you are a man
instead of simply being bitter if you
want to be better put in the work to
become the best version of yourself
physically emotionally spiritually
financially if you commit to that for
three years of your life
see what happens to your outcomes
compound interest
literally
[Music]
you